NAME A FEW.
BUT FIRST, MY OPEN.
WE WERE IN A DARK AND DANGEROUS
PLACE IN AMERICA WHERE POLITICS
IS DRIVING OUR SYSTEM OF
JUSTICE.
INSTEAD OF LADY JUSTICE BEING
BLIND TO POLITICS.
THE STORY OF LIEUTENANT GENERAL
LIKELE FLYNN, IN THE END IT'S SO
MUCH BIGGER THAN POLITICS.
WHETHER USUAL LEFT, RIGHT,
AGNOSTIC OR INDIFFERENT.
AT ITS CORE, THIS IS A STORY OF
INJUSTICE.
IT INVOLVES THE USUAL PLAYERS,
PROTAGONISTS, ANTAGONISTS.
PRETTY MUCH KNOW THE WHO, WHAT,
WHERE, WHEN, AND HOW.
THE FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION.
ON JANUARY 24, 017 WAS MICHAEL
FLYNN TREATED AS PER THE RULES
LIKE ANY OTHER FBI TARGET?
THE ANSWER A RESOUNDING NO.
HE WAS TREATED DIFFERENTLY.
WHICH BRINGS US TO THE QUESTION,
WHY?
THE ANSWER TO WHY BRINGS US TO
AN UNSETTLING PLACE.
FOREIGN TO ALL OF US WHO HAVE
SPENT OUR CAREERS REVERING THE
AMERICAN SYSTEM OF JUSTICE.
IT IS THAT SYSTEM OF JUSTICE
THAT DISTINGUISHES US FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES.
WE ARE FAIR, WE STRIVE TO
ACHIEVE JUSTICE FOR ALL.
NO ONE IS ABOVE OUR LAW, AND NO
ONE IS BENEATH IT.
IT'S WHY PEOPLE CLAMOR TO COME
HERE LEGALLY AND ILLEGALLY.
AS STRONG AS THE STATUE OF
LIBERTY IS IN THE HARBOR OF NEW
YORK.
IT ALSO IS A SYMBOL OF BLIND
LADY JUSTICE IN COURTROOMS
ACROSS THIS GREAT NATION.
THE FACTS OF THIS STORY ARE
SIMPLE.
FLYNN WAS IN THE CROSS-HAIRS OF
THE FBI, TARGETED BY THE SAME
PLAYERS WHO WHEN KNOW FROM
PUBLICIZED TEXT MESSAGES AND
EMAILS TRYING TO PREVENT A
CERTAIN CANDIDATE FROM BECOMING
PRESIDENT AND PROMOTE ANOTHER.
THEY WERE DIRT WHICH, THEY WERE
LIARS, THEY WERE LEAKERS, AND
THEY WERE CORRUPT.
THERE IS ONE IMPORTANT FACT THAT
YOU NEED TO REMEMBER.
THE CONVERSATION FLYNN HAD WITH
THE RUSSIAN AMBASSADOR DURING
THE TRANSITION WAS LEGAL.
PERFECTLY LEGAL.
TAKE THAT ONE TO THE BANK.
IT IS WHAT IS DONE IN EVERY NEW
ADMINISTRATION.
THE SETUP, MICHAEL FLYNN WAS
CALLED BY DEPUTY FBI DIRECTOR
ANDREW McCABE AND TOLD THAT
THE FBI WANTED TO TALK TO FLYNN
ABOUT THE RUGS.
AND THE QUICKEST WAY TO DO IT
WAS TO KEEP THE LAWYERS OUT.
A CLEAR VIOLATION OF PROTOCOL,
WHITE HOUSE RULES, AND
ULTIMATELY FLYNN'S
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
WE KNOW THIS BECAUSE U.S.
DISTRICT COURT JUDGE EMMITT
SULLIVAN ORDERED PROSECUTORS TO
HAND OVER FBI FILES OF THE FLYNN
INTERROGATION INSTEAD OF
EXTENSION HIM AS SCHEDULES.
48 HOURS LATER THE FILES ARE
HANDED OVER AS PER THE JUDGE'S
DIRECTIVE.
ALTHOUGH INCOMPLETE AND
REDACTED.
THEY CONFIRM WHAT DIRECTOR COMEY
HIMSELF ADMITTED.
AND WHAT THE JUDGE APPARENTLY
SUSPECTED.
THE DOJ AND FBI HATCHED A PLAN
TO DELIBERATELY AND
INTENTIONALLY AVOID PROTOCOL,
STANDARD OPERATING PROCEDURE IN
AN EFFORT TO ENTRAP MICHAEL
FLYNN.
COMEY EVEN ADMITS IT WHEN HE
PULLS OFF THE MASK OF CARDINAL
COMEY TO REVEAL THE FACE OF A
HARDENED POLITICAL OPERATIVE WHO
DELIBERATELY TRAPPED ANYONE.
HE NOT ONLY ADMITTED IT, HE
BRIDED HIMSELF ON WHAT ANY OTHER
DECENT MAN OF HONOR WOULD HAVE
BEEN HORRIFIED TO ADMIT.
THAT THE RULES, THE LAW, AND THE
CONSTITUTION MATTER NOT WHEN
POLITICS IS AT STAKE.
>> SOMETHING I PROBABLY WOULDN'T
HAVE DONE OR MAYBE GONE THE AWAY
WITH IN A MORE ORGANIZED
INVESTIGATION -- MORE ORGANIZED
ADMINISTRATION, IN THE GEORGE W.
BUSH OR OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
JUDGE JEANINE: SOMETHING HE
WOULDN'T HAVE GONE THE AWAY WITH
IN ANY OTHER ADMINISTRATION?
TO BE CLEAR.
THE FBI WENT TO GREAT LENGTHS TO
DISAVOW FLYNN OF ANY CONCERNS.
TELLING HIM YOUR LAWYER DOESN'T
NEED TO BE THERE.
A PLAN COMEY AND STRZOK AND PAGE
STRATEGIZED TO KEEP THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE OUT.
WE KNOW THERE WERE MANY
ARGUMENTS ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
THEY COULD AND SHOULD DO THIS.
YOU MAY BE SITTING THERE SAYING
HEY, FLYNN WAS A GENERAL, HE
SHOULD HAVE KNOWN NOT TO LIE.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
BUT WHAT IS A LIE?
IS IT A MISTAKE?
A MISREMEMBRANCE, A MEMORY THAT
DOESN'T REMEMBER EVERYTHING.
OR UNTRUTH.
IF AN UNTRUTH DOESN'T REQUIRE AN
INTENT TO DECEIVE TO BE A LIE.
FLYNN KNEW THAT ANY CONVERSATION
HE HAD WITH THE RUSSIANS WAS
RECORD AND THE FBI WOULD
CERTAINLY HAVE A TRANSCRIPT OF
HIS CONVERSATION WITH THE
RUSSIAN AMBASSADOR SO THERE
WOULD BE NO POINT IN LYING.
EVEN MORE COMPELLING.
AGENT STRZOK AND OTHER FBI AGENT
TO INTERVIEWED FLYNN SAY HE DID
NOT LIE.
QUOTE.
BOTH HAD THE IMPRESSION AT THE
TIME THAT FLYNN WAS NOT LYING.
AND DID NOT THINK HE WAS LYING.
THEY EVEN SAID HE WAS UNGUARD
AND FRIENDLY.
THE NOTES FURTHER DESCRIBE THAT
FLYNN DID NOT GIVE ANY
INDICATION OF DECEPTION.
CURIOUS, HOWEVER, IS THE FALL
OUR OF THE FBI AND THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL TO PROVIDE THE FBI'S 302
OF FLYNN TO JUDGE SULLIVAN.
HOW DOES THE FBI FILE A FALSE
STATEMENT CHARGE WHEN THE FBI
THOUGHT IT WAS IN LIE.
YOU ARE PROBABLY ASKING
YOURSELF, WHY WOULD FLYNN EVEN
PLEAD GUILTY TO LYING WHEN HE
WASN'T LYING.
THE ANSWER?
FLYNN BASED ON HIS RECORD OF 33
YEARS AS A DECORATED MILITARY
MAN IS AN HONORABLE MAN WHO MAY
HAVE REALIZED WHEN HE SAW THE
TRANSCRIPT THAT WHAT HE SAID WAS
NOT CONSISTENT WITH THE
TRANSCRIPT.
ER.
>> MAYBE HE PLED GUILTY BECAUSE
HE RAN OUT OF MONEY TO DEFEND
HIMSELF.
EVEN HAVING TO SELL HIS HOUSE TO
SURVIVE.
OR MAYBE TO SAVE HIS SON, ALSO
IN THE CROSS-HAIRS OF THESE
PEOPLE.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO THINK THE
FBI WAS JUST TRYING TO GET TO
THE TRUTH, YOU ARE WRONG.
IF THEY WANTED INFORMATION, IF
THEY WANTED THE TRUTH, THEY
COULD HAVE SHOWN FLYNN HIS
TRANSCRIPT OF HIS CONVERSATION
TO REFRESH HIS RECOLLECTION TO
GET AT THE TRUTH.
BUT, NO, THEY DIDN'T WANT THE
TRUTH.
THEY WANTED TO TAKE DOWN A BIT
PLAYER TO GET TO THE BIG PLAYER.
TUESDAY THE PARTIES WILL APPEAR
AGAIN BEFORE JUDGE EMMETT
SULLIVAN, A JUDGE UNAFRAID OF
THE SWAMP.
A JUDGE WITH A TRACK RECORD OF
CALLING OUT PROSECUTORIAL
MISCONDUCT.
A JUDGE WHO DOES NOT PERMIT
INJUSTICE OR ABUSE OF POWER.
THE JUDGE CAN THROW OUT THIS
GUILTY PLEA IF HE CONCLUDES THE